[Music]
sup
welcome to the quarter cast again
it's another week
it's a week between weeks a week between
weeks a week between two other weeks
that's beautiful
it's true we filmed the second
season of son of a dungeon last week
well the first half of it
we're filming the next next week
it's really intense
it's like imagine writing game of
thrones
and then having to memorize half of it
and then your actors are always
constantly like giving you
like feedback on the script they're like
you know i think my character would say
this i'm like that's fine and then later
like down the line two scenes later
you're like oh crap that totally changes
this scene
because of that other and then you're so
you're constantly rewriting the script
as you're filming it
um
so kind of like game of thrones so like
game of thrones
yeah as the seasons are coming out they
are rewriting the show
exactly
um
yeah
a lot of things happened last week in
the uh world of of uh
what is the world called we don't even
have a name for it the world
like earth
like the world of cecilton and
wentingham shot oh uh i'll think of that
yeah we'll think of something like that
it'll be like um
you know
freaking
fairyland or something
you know like but that's
fairyland
make believe place make-believe place
land of toys
sam's toy chest
magnificent toy chest
the twisted mind is of sam gorski
yeah yeah
so um what were you guys just doing we
delayed this podcast for like a half
hour because there was some scanning
going on i don't know what happened i'll
let jordan explain yeah we were doing
some foot stuff
[Laughter]
as you do ren was photo scanning his
foot yeah but i thought it was funny
because i like
for a second i thought ren needed
jordan's foot
for a project he's working on he needs
it more than he knows but then i
realized oh he's just scanning the foot
it's jordan needs his own foot
yeah
that's exactly right it's a terrible
squid that you know that's not a bad
idea you can put it on sketch fab at
least well i was looking i was looking
for a good foot model like a really good
ultra realistic foot model
and i couldn't find one so
my own feet are sacrificed it's funny
and for some reason you need variations
you need like dirty
dirty clean clean and those are the
variations
the only two states of existence dirty
and clean yeah that's it exactly that's
all there is sam what was this image of
this photo scan you put out earlier that
said you took less photos of it that
thing looked really good real sam took a
photo scan what was what happened
and then the other photographs
photo scanning for those of you don't
know
uh uh
it's when you take a bunch of pictures
of an object and you give it to a
program and the program magically makes
it a 3d model
um
so they're scanning feet
um and i'm scanning the like huge table
maps for son of a dungeon
but uh previously we're doing like 700
to like even at one point we did like
1200 over a thousand pictures for a map
and i was like this is not the way to do
this so i tried a new technique where
uh i take way less photos i took like
350 photos this time which is basically
half
but using a different technique of just
making sure there's like really clear
crisp wide shots
and keeping it minimal
um
it's just like
it looks
almost photo real
uh and like the detail is like is it's
like as if you were to take it and bring
it like right next to your eye and look
at it and
are you getting that level of detail
across the entire map image now or was
it basically one yeah so the first the
first table is like is like a it's like
a b
maybe a b minus if i had to rate it and
then this most recent one is like a it's
like an a
uh it's not like an a plus or like s
plus you know or
you know a god tier anything
do they still do that do they still give
out japanese racing games
is that like a japanese school thing
you've been to japan do you you take a
peek in any classrooms
you know you get all the answers right
you got all the answers right plus the
extra credit questions so you get an s
and then you status all the extra credit
and also you did all the tests right and
also you're handsome so it's s plus
and then you got the test right and the
extra credit and you're handsome and you
did it faster than anybody else you're a
triple s that's about true i used to get
i used to get s pluses in elementary
school that's true actually so that's
satisfactory that was like a solid and
then s minus you're like less than
satisfactory it's like and then ns no it
was you was it you
unsatisfactory yeah button
but
why change why not do abc like you might
not do that abc kids because they're
like freaking two years old like
look you did better than you did better
than half so you got it okay let's move
on to the next thing
but like you know when you get older
then you know it's like well how how
much above half did i did i get
i need to know well i mean but there's
already multiple you have a not
satisfactory and then s minus s and s
plus
it's like
that's like a b c d
why did they skip e thank you
thank you where's e
where the heck is he i guess i just like
uh once you're doing a d level you're
just a failure so because just like
[Laughter]
is
c is uh
better
compliments
it goes like this
it goes
things
left to be desired
division
i've got it i've got it and then they're
like and then
they're like oh let's just skip that
like if you're at an e you basically
already fail are failing anyways so i
want to hear jake's jake's
set of letters
a is average
b is bad
c is a damn catastrophe
and what is d cap no c is catastrophe d
is damn catastrophe
d and f do not exist it's you are done
it's that you are done when you get a d
there's goodbye
yeah
aced it so why did they even have the
most competent because they're like
means fail but then you're like
you're failing if you have these two
not really well in in grad in grad
school you you do in grad school they'll
kick you out of law school if you don't
maintain a a uh
b minus average
well
they'll just kick you out
because they know you're not likely to
pass the bar exam and so they don't want
to drag down their school's numbers on
like passage rate
so then they'll just like
go all right you almost got kept out
yeah i did
i did when we were filming sync i almost
failed i almost flunked out it wasn't
flunky see it wasn't flunking it was
like i almost c-plused my way out
[Laughter]
is that the the california bar exam is
so hard that and the passage rate is so
low to begin with that they um
it's just like a
ravenous
competition to like get you know
because because what you don't want is
like oh
the kids from this law school have a
lower than average passing rate then all
of a sudden people will be like oh that
means like uh that's not a good school
you know i'm not likely to pass
the exam if i if i do that what is
average what what's an average passing
rate for the bar
do you know off the top of your head
i think it's like 45 percent
so what happens if you don't pass it you
just don't you just do something else
you're forever banned from average
california
you can try to yesterday you get barred
yeah just you ended up spending a
thousand bucks and you just gotta
give another shot yeah uh first timers
uh
let's see
wait you're 45 you're so you're talking
lawyers out there get half the questions
wrong
no 45 of the people who take the exam
pass it the first time oh oh god okay
but then
people who take it more than once second
timers it's like it it falls off even
further
um they've got really
hard stats on this
oh i bet they do all applicants oh okay
it's gone up slightly
pass rate for general bar exam by law
school just because people were
complaining about it first-timers now 66
god just let anybody become a lawyer
these days
i know they'll just let anybody in then
pass rate for repeated applicants
hey so supposedly that guy can catch me
if you can
frank dearbot pass the bar just by
studying really hard
is you know that's possible do you pass
the bar with like two weeks of cramming
that was the louisiana bar um and i'm
not
no i'm not
i'm not dishing a dissing on louisiana
um i but they uh have a different
process there it's more it's like more
feudal
let me look it up there is difference
apparently he actually didn't pass the
bar this is one of his many cons
he conned us into thinking he actually
did that what a man yeah so you don't
need to go to liar okay a graduate of
a law school accredited by the aba
okay so you do ha you do need it now but
for a long time and i assume it was in
the same way in louisiana in the 1960s
you didn't need to have to have gone to
a a law school
in order to
sit for the exam it was just like well
if you can pass it you i guess you can
you can do it wait so that's not a thing
anymore
that
over time it has become more of a thing
where the requirement is now
you need to have a juris doctorate
degree in order to sit for the exam
there's some loopholes in different
states but
back in the day
before like the concept of law school
was like a thing
and it slowly became more of a thing
people could just sit for the exam
huh feels like
i don't know
what do you think jake was that the
right move
well sorry say that again was that the
right move do you think that was the
right move
sorry go say what you said before that
because you cut out for a second oh i'm
just saying do you think do you think
making it so you have to go to law
school to become a lawyer
was the right move
or do you think people should be able to
take the test regardless
it's it's an interesting
it's an interesting question i think
there's merits to both
um i mean the downside to requiring
people to go to school is obviously that
you you you now have this pretty arduous
like
time and money burden
where you're like hey now you need to go
you know anywhere from two to four years
depending on the program that you're in
it's gonna cost you anywhere between
a hundred thousand to three hundred
thousand dollars depending on the school
and the time
and that's what you have to do just to
sit for the exam
right like right you're not you're not a
lawyer yet you just just to sit for the
exam
um so but the the upside to that is like
you
people that want to do it take on a big
risk and then the people that actually
are able to get the license to practice
now you know
there's a lot more that went into it
than just hey i studied under a lawyer
or i you know i studied for a few months
and then i sat for it and passed it now
just but then the the other side is like
who can sit for it and for after
studying for like a couple months and
just pass it like you're not
you know yeah i guess so yeah and then
the other the other side of that too is
like there's all these sort of like
other triggers in place
within the profession itself that
like
you know
sort of guard against like male practice
and things like that now um you know
people that have bad experiences or
people that sue for malpractice i'm sure
would have different differing opinions
on that
but um
what's the secret lawyer handshake look
like
a secret lawyer handshake yeah what will
you show us the secret lawyer handshake
no i can't do that that would be i
almost had them it would be i could get
disbarred from the podcast nobody can
see it
yeah we can't see below your elbows
no
you might somebody in the future might
be able to decipher the wind patterns
that i make with my hands yeah and then
using ai turn it into a physical image
to be back
hey guys jake here courtesy of today's
sponsor manscaped to tell you about the
performance package 4.0 just in time for
valentine's day now this little beauty
has everything you're going to need to
keep yourself looking fresh feeling
fresh and just being awesome this
valentine's day when you're out on your
hot date let me tell you about what's in
this performance package first and
foremost it has the lawnmower 4.0 this
is manscape's signature trimmer okay the
fourth generation this little beauty has
a 4000k led light so it's easy to see in
those hard to reach places it also has
the advanced skin safe technology on the
trimmer meaning that you're less likely
to cut or nick yourself in those
uncomfortable places and it has a
cordless recharger but that's not all
they got in here they also have the weed
whacker nose and ear trimmer just for
you this thing has a 9
000 rpm motor powered 360 degree rotary
dual blade system but in addition to
this you're also going to get the free
shed travel bag and the anti-chafing
boxer briefs directly from manscape
these boxers honestly they're great
boxers the lawnmower trimmer is great
all their products are phenomenal i have
been using them obviously since they've
been sponsoring the podcast i've been
trying everything out and using
everything and i gotta say it's all
top-notch it's clean it's fresh and it's
nice and it's good quality it's it's
really good quality so that's what's in
this beautiful performance package 4.0
and if you guys are interested in
getting your hands on it or any other
manscaped products that they have to
offer head on over to manscaped.com and
use the promo code cord or cast to get
20 off plus free shipping so once again
huge thanks to them for sponsoring
you're welcome and let's get back to the
podcast
so jordan i'm
kind of curious about this foot thing
still still your feet are still on my
mind um right
it happens
what's so so it's part of the next video
which is a
disgusting render challenge yeah
are we sure that's a good idea no no
we're not this is a terrible
i guess apparently he was like about to
throw up or something like do we have a
rule recorder we don't make anything
intentionally bad
[Laughter]
bad in the sense that it's intentionally
without craft yeah we said this about
the unsatisfying render challenge though
and for months we stayed away from it
and it turned out people loved it yeah
there's a certain satisfaction in it i
think we were looking at some videos
yesterday and and absolutely repulsive
getting in the spirit of things yeah a
guy who was like yeah i've got a cyst on
my leg and it's been like 30 years
it's like yeah he you somehow
for some reason waited 30 years to deal
with it imagine having a 30-year
problem
like that on a lazy
[ __ ] did you get bigger and bigger
yeah yeah i know what a weird why state
of mind imagine like it's like yeah you
don't clean your room for 30 years you
don't like take a shower for 30 years
it's like it's in the same category yeah
you have this giant ball of pus on your
leg
anyway so the video is they cut it open
um you have a strong stomach i will say
i i was almost on the floor i felt sick
and sam just stared it down
yeah just eyeballed it the whole time
so i'm just like all right let's do it
i was quivering but i stealed my nerves
the clotted cream it was very oh my god
see everybody's turning out the podcast
now like not only are you guys ruining
the video you're wearing the podcast
what about your feet is so uh
disgusting
it's not because i saw them and frankly
you know there's a little dirt here and
there yeah they could be better but
they're not the worst and uh yeah i
can't give away too much of multiple
times jordan i have i have like long
feet
which i don't know if that's an
advantage like i can maybe i can run a
little faster
michael phelps thing going on there well
i guess they're not that long i'm size
11.
i'm sorry
i'll never be
[Laughter]
yeah it's part of the render though it's
like just uh just a part of the reveal
of what i'm working on because we we
kind of decided to go with some phobias
that we had
in the uh nasty community and and for me
feet are repulsive i just have i have a
difficult time with them so thankfully
society has agreed that in public we
cover them yeah
yeah thank god thank god at least you
covered the bottom of them
yeah well they're uncovered now i mean
uh there's a there's a highly detailed
speech
yeah get it now
you know once we hit
70.
whatever our next million sub mark it's
the giveaway on the crew channel will be
the foot reveal
the turbo squid crew foot reveal
oh my gosh can i add that to the time
capsule yes my my foot yes get that in
there yeah dig up the time capsule so we
can add more stuff into it is that thing
really still in the dirt back there
i think so
would they buried a microwave or
something right someone's gonna dig that
up one day
it'll be funny on the bill yeah they'll
load it up and it's these videos these
3d models of petering wren dancing or
whatever
it's like what the hell
are you gonna do a render for this
challenge i want to but i'm concerned
that my time is a little fractured
but i have ideas i just
need to buckle down and doom
i think i think it'll go over well i
hope
yeah it might be simple
but it'll be disturbing or disgusting
yeah i get the two confused and there's
a there's a fine line too we don't want
to venture into gore territory
we're we're going with stuff that just
turns the stomach yeah watchable you
know keeping it keeping it pg
you know keeping it you you're keeping
it pg
our feet pg
there's feet and
are you sure that's pg i don't know if
just disgusting renders this pg
yeah i think you're right i think i'm
missing
13.
teens only
yet you're 13 years old to watch us what
are we grading
pg 13 plus
yeah that's what say you can see the f
bomb twice in a pg-13 movie
i got carded on a
date when i was i think i was 24. and i
got cards for a rated r movie
i got carded for a pg
pg
you want to see happy feet yeah
can you tell us about this experience
where you got carded for an hour maybe
it was a first date and things were
things were i would give things maybe a
b-plus
at to that point
and uh you know we went to go see uh who
was it it was uh it was like a war movie
of some kind i can't remember rated r
just uh real edgy stuff for a first date
you know it's the kind of guy that i am
yeah and uh we walk up there and it's
not a comedy of course not a comedy
that's so funny yeah first date it's
like yesterday
private ryan here we go it's like yeah
set in the mood it was it's calculated
it was a based in based in world war ii
do you want to go see schindler's list
highly visual war drama um yeah and yeah
i mean she gets her ticket just fine and
i go up right behind like we're the only
two there clearly this is a date
and you know it's already proven that
she's 24 25 at this point and i walk up
and she was carded no she was not carded
but how was it proven well i guess she
she wasn't carded by transparency
so that she's doing something very
illegal or just maybe give me a ticket
to the movies
are you lost son
i don't know what his problem was but
yeah he he looked me up and down and he
said show me your id oh my gosh i think
it was sure he wasn't just like flexing
like maybe he was power move he's like
oh look he's too sweet there's people on
a date this beautiful couple watch me
like like i'm jealous
he watched me yeah makes sense
yeah it's like hey you look like you're
two
roasted
yeah so i had to take out my idea
and that was uncomfortable for everybody
i think for the rest of the day you know
you think about
what people around you start to think
and he's like why i questioned his age
turns out he wasn't 13.
how old do you have to be to get into an
r movie 17 16 i think isn't it is it 17
i think it's 17. 16 year olds can't
handle it no you have to be 17. so so
you so this girl that you are on this
date with was legitimately wondering if
you were 17
yeah i hope she wasn't
she
agreed to go out so i certainly hope
that wasn't on her mind
okay remember how they used to not make
rated r content because they didn't
think it would make any money
like they would only make movies after
like pg-13 and like rarely was a rated r
movie because
just they wouldn't perform in theaters
and then air force that's still been a
thing all the way up until like modern
blockbusters yeah but now we have
streaming so it's less of a thing like
air force one came out and that was the
first like rated r movie to break a
certain threshold like 100 million
dollars or something like that i was
like oh my gosh
air force one proved that you can make
radar movies that succeed in the box
office
so there you have it open season
everyone's kidding me
terminator 2
oh came out years before that i know
that but hey i'm not an executive one
wait what are you yeah
because that's how hollywood is they're
like aliens an alien
and 22 giant box office success
terminator 2 is rated r terminator 2 was
like gangbusters right i don't know i
feel like
500 it made 520 million in the box
office its budget was a hundred million
so when terminator 2 came out i was
dying to see it and i was like like what
freaking
[Laughter]
it must have been 96 or something and
they're still pumping out terminator
toys
and i'm seeing these terminator toys
going like this movie must be the
coolest movie
and it took still years after that for
me to actually watch it but
terminator 2 3d want to rate it
automatically capture a child's
imagination i don't know were you
allowed to watch raided our movies as a
kid
uh yes yes sam had all the coolest
movies
like you know anime yeah my dad would be
like all right it's a sick day and he'd
hand me like a vhs of akira when i'm
like 11. it's the same day i'm serious i
watched it when i was like in fifth or
sixth grade and i was just like
what the [ __ ]
i even made him get me like an akira
t-shirt when i was like in sixth grade
and i'd be wearing at the school i'm
like oh man this is so edgy i'm like the
biggest edgelord right now because it's
a rated r movie
did you ever get carded like video
update or blockbuster or anything like
that yeah i don't remember any of that
craft here i worked that one you know i
never walked back into the yeah
wait wait yeah i should have you worked
at a movie rental place i worked at the
video update in stillwater yeah yeah i
worked there for like a half a year only
it was like a half years like basically
just did you get free rentals yeah yeah
it was great oh hell yeah i just watched
tons of movies i've rent all the games i
want too and just oh nice played
games all summer and watched all these
crazy movies
dude it's like netflix before
netflix no yeah
it was awesome it was awesome because
like yeah you'd get all like the new
stuff in every week on tuesday and you'd
like take it before it goes on the
shelves and watch it and
i forgot about that like if there's a
popular new movie coming out like you
had a good chance of not being able to
watch it
you couldn't get it you could not get it
yeah tough times like did anybody just
return it can you process your returns
please so i can see if it's in there and
sometimes be like fine
that's yeah oh yeah the little slots for
the vhs
return oh yeah dude i used to ride my
bike to video updates so i could rent in
10 to 64 games so you rent them for one
week for like five bucks
yeah what a deal video i've never heard
of video update yeah blockbuster i'm
very familiar it's a very re it's a
regional thing let's see let's see what
happened to the video update like
hollywood video
was actually down the street from video
update okay there's a lot of employee
theft hollywood video in fact hollywood
video is so rife with employee theft
that everybody in my high school and my
grade like knows about it
everyone has a vhs yeah and they also
hollywood video was the scummy video
randy yeah he says you actually read
your games from hollywood video because
sometimes the employees would be so
stoned that they'd forget to scan them
correctly so when you bring it back
they'd be like oh this this doesn't say
it's checked out this isn't ours and
they let you keep it
so yeah that's incredible yeah you could
get games that way oh that's incredible
yeah that's right okay video update here
we go
it started maybe in eagan minnesota i'm
trying to figure out where it's oh it's
a minnesota thing
yeah
just a you know it's like a family video
it's another one of those local video
chains rending video games man what a
nostalgia
yeah
like because i i didn't have any video
game consoles until i was in high school
and so like yeah birthday party it's
like we're renting an n64 for the day
and it's just like yeah
oh my god playing like need for speed or
whatever those games were on that and
oh my god and 64 was such a game changer
oh yeah and ps4 oh my
i pronounced it
respect
yeah you shoot the dinosaurs and they go
flying and there's like these blood
trails that just drip down for some
reason you're like yeah yeah games are
all about what kind of gore graphics
could you do
was it was the other game uh
soldier of fortune soldier fortune two
so that's the glorious yeah i remember
finding a box of the game and i flip it
over and they're like we've dissected
the human body into 46 different like
these pieces you could dismember with
the weapons in this game
and it was just like jesus christ
it was awesome
you could shoot people like if you shot
somebody through a glass window the
glass would shatter and stick into the
character model and so like you shotgun
somebody they'd always glass shards
stuck in them on top of all the damage
so brutal it's super gorgeous i haven't
ever heard of this game before soldier
fortune it was like the like gory
shooter game it was like yeah it was
like cutting edge i wasn't allowed i
wasn't allowed near those uh mature
titles and rated r movies like the movie
that always eluded me as a kid i used to
collect jackie chan vhs movies every
week i'd go and buy another one because
i'd get six dollars a week oh wow and
they were six dollars
but all the rated r catalog were off the
table for me so rumble in the bronx was
like the coveted oh
why is that rated r that's right i don't
know
how many times did you say the f-word
i don't want any [ __ ] trouble
i don't know i mean i've seen it now i
love it and i i don't get it either
yeah you know wow what no wait dude i
came guys 6.8 out of 10.
that's insane wait what's the 20 out of
10. the imdb is a joke yeah
2.8 6.8 out of 10.
way better than 6.8
there's probably the grandmas that
watched it and they're like i can't
handle all these high kicks
oh all these these outtakes at the end
when it's a ladder fight not funny
they're all making trouble this is all
they are all having trouble right now
they're all making trouble and i can't
abide by that so one star it's too real
two stars there's too much crime in new
york city and this is just making more
children want to be
criminals
karate criminals
yeah
all right video up video update was
acquired out of bankruptcy in 2001 by a
competitor movie gallery incorporated
movie gallery i remember moving that
company the country's second biggest
movie and game rental business behind
blockbuster went out of business in
2010. oh my god what an ugly time to be
in the video rental game
video update went out in 2001
and then it was acquired by another
company which went out of business in
2010 but there was one video update
store in eagan minnesota
that lasted until 2012. oh my gosh for
two decades
jim and dave lozinski
owned and operated their own
video update store
even as the company's fortune fell the
two applied for and received a lifetime
franchise license to keep their business
open
as far as we know we're the last ones
worldwide said jim on friday afternoon
wow wow and then they went out into in
2012 just couldn't keep up yeah end of a
lifetime the writing was on the wall
let's be real yeah i think the writing
was on the wall
game stops like the only like chain from
that era that's like held on yeah i
don't think they're gonna hold on much
longer though i tend to agree with that
too i i'm kind of surprised they've made
it as long as they have yeah they got a
nice little boost i guess this past year
somehow through stuff yeah they did
yeah
they're gonna watch that burn away over
the next two years here
there's still a blockbuster left though
there still was one in existence right
oregon or something like that or
washington yeah quirky blockbuster video
there's one in bend oregon
[Music]
that's crazy
wow
inherent organization viacom oh wow
viacom owns the one blockbuster
apparently
apparently that's funny um
i remember one of my buddies got like
the hard drive for the playstation 2
back in the day
and you could actually copy games onto
it so you just go to blockbuster and
rent a ps2 game copy it to his hard
drive and then return it and he just
would slowly build up his library of
games by doing that
oh that's genius
you could do that with movie rentals too
of course you could rip the dvds and
whatever
yeah i feel like i had a great i had my
favorite two vcr players man we can copy
terminator 2 judgement day
own it forever
whatever i want yeah there was a there
was a greater appreciation i think for
me back when it was harder to get these
things yeah you know we're like
inundated with insane shows and
movies on demand all the time and like
going to blockbuster and finding it
and then getting it and getting it home
and then rewinding it
and then playing it
someone was not kind and forgot to
rewind
yeah
man yeah what a time
i missed that me too
now it's like uh i don't know what
subscription service i want to watch
tonight there's just so much content i
can't even decide
so i've made a mistake with my
subscription services by the way i've
made a horrible mistake
i'll i'll advise all you guys so you
don't fall into the same pit that i'm in
so
you know i get netflix i'm like you know
for christmas this year is like 2015.
i'm gonna get you know i'm gonna get a
family account for netflix i'm gonna
give a login to my mom my dad ivy's
parents and then we were still living so
i still use sarah
i mean if you can politely ask me to
like no keep using it not use
[Laughter]
we were added as family members
yeah i remember the day we got our own
amazon account it was big happenings but
you know so i get netflix and like
another girls around or all the parents
we love the netflix gift we hope you'll
keep doing it that's fine i'll keep
doing it like this you know i want to
watch something on hulu so i'm gonna get
hulu or game of thrones all right guys
for this christmas you guys get hbo
subscriptions here's i got a family
account for hbo and like so now at this
point
like all of ivy's always ivy's parents
my parents like they have our hbo our
hulu our netflix so now i'm like i don't
i don't give a crap about hbo right now
i don't need hbo i don't watch netflix
right now i'm not watching anything and
i go to cancel like wait i can't cancel
it because now this is like this is
their present like and now i'm like
permanently subscribed to like six
streaming services because oh yeah so
many christmas presents spotify's and
netflix's and like i can't stop i can't
get out of it now i'm forced into
subscribing for like for everybody
that's brutal now you just gotta set
aside a portion of the budget each month
just for so
netflix you got your hbos don't forget
peacock it's an important one
uh hulu's
you get your paramount pluses you got
your peacocks
flirty i subscribe to very mountain plus
like no i guess
youtube premium is dope because
youtube thank god google
who is an ad company has let people
subvert their ads by just giving a
couple bucks yeah because
oh my gosh actually i got to keep add so
i can see what's actually out there
because it's kind of our business what
do you see what are you looking for
nothing i just need to see what the what
what is the ad experience like on
youtube so i i just say yeah i mean yeah
i catch them every once in a while
over the shoulders of the less fortunate
but
i'm just saying like i wish instagram oh
my god if instagram did that thank god
but i did immediately unsubscribe i i
did subscribe to youtube premium when
milo started watching youtube videos
like there's no way i'm gonna let my
two-year-old deal with it youtube oh my
god i know i feel so sorry for all the
children out there who's like
just getting blasted with ads that are
i'm not at all vetted for children or
anything like that it's like youtube is
like a wasteland for kids it is just
rotting their brains
hours of content every
minute
yeah i mean i like gideon watch youtube
but it's the thing where it's like all
right
x time per day and then also like
i constantly like tap him on one
shoulder and he looks and then i like
make mute a ton of these channels so
they'd never pop up ever
[Laughter]
yeah like you you have to be like on it
yeah
very working there is there are people
who are like there are people existing
who make decent kids shows
on youtube
yeah but there's also
not too there's a lot of people who are
just like oh yeah like that one guy i'm
not gonna say his name or where we talk
to him but yeah i remember that one guy
he was like yeah it doesn't matter whose
fingers they are in there it doesn't
matter we can still watch it
what's the context of that
toys and stuff
talk about creepy gross render
challenges that's the worst thing
he's talking about like kids videos
where he's like they're playing with
toys and it was like he was like saying
yeah it doesn't give no one gives a [ __ ]
whose fingers are in there you know just
you know see anyone can do and so we're
doing like 20 channels like this where
it's like
yeah he had a whole thing going where he
had a he had an empire he had a
slumlords empire of channels
[Laughter]
just of like kids opening toys and
things like that and like
yeah he was going on about it to us
about how
it was a whole business and we were just
sitting there going like this
the whole unboxing thing is fascinating
just in terms of like why that's why
that's unattractive
like
why do people like watching unboxing is
it the experience of
opening something for yourself is that
i guess so
it's just just product porn yeah yeah i
suppose it's just yeah that's a
consumerism
little dopamine hit loot boxes you know
ah fair fair yeah
i still wonder our child psychologist
reacts to youtube kids videos
and just get to hear about just how
rough it is
i actually did a little presentation for
youtube back when they had the product
team in in la
and the main point i like so the product
team is the team that makes the actual
like interface the the product youtube
um
and
one of the things i was focused on like
in my presentation was the fact they had
zero regulations for kids as actors
because in hollywood like you have to
have a teacher on set you can't have
them on set past a certain hour you can
only have eight hours a day
if you're doing an extended shoot then
you get schooling on the shoot like uh
you
if you pay the kids it goes to a trust
in their name so the parents can't take
the money there's always laws and
regulations same thing with like with
television if you are playing kids media
you can't have uh cereals or candy in
your commercials you can't do toys
between certain hours when young kids
are home from school
uh so like all the ads are regulated too
but none of that exists on youtube so
people are going on youtube and making
millions literally millions of dollars
exploiting their kids and there's no
regulations protecting those kids
there's none of that that guarantees
that they're getting schooling there's
nothing like is a complete wild west and
that was my whole presentation like you
guys need to start getting your act
together otherwise i guarantee you in
about eight years you're gonna start
getting stories of people going coming
out and being like youtube exploited me
you know
yeah i have a thought on this um
because this is coming up again right
with what just happened like last late
last year with instagram
and you know they're saying yeah it's
like instagram for kids that thing
well no the whole like hey we have
empirical evidence that instagram is
like yeah
specifically
and
have we done anything about it no no we
haven't no have you done anything about
it at all
no no we really haven't even though you
have empirical evidence that shows that
and you guys already know about it
yeah we have the lights i haven't done
anything
yeah
um
so
are we too far gone are we too far gone
like are we past the point of of people
being able to be like hey
there needs to be some regulation here
i i don't think so but honestly my hope
is that
the natural regulation of people getting
bored with [ __ ] is gonna like actually
influence this where at a certain point
people be like eh i'm over it
i don't really care about instagram
anymore i don't care about the like
because at a certain point it's gonna be
old news what about the babies being
born now they're like
tick tock whatever i don't like that's
what's happening here's twitter right
now you know what's that that people are
just like i don't care about twitter or
well it's i mean
i don't know if this is directly tied to
its use but it's stock price since like
mid last year
is basically halved oh yes because
there's no way they can make any money
that's the thing that's why it's halved
yeah
well it's this is the whole weird thing
that's it is weird it's it's super weird
because like
i think the last like since it's
basically since trump became president
is where everyone's come kind of having
this coming to terms with this concept
of social media yeah like the regulation
here because
once trump started running for president
it was like everyone was like we don't
get like previously he was like oh yeah
there's [ __ ] on facebook but now
it's like oh hey the president and the
people surrounding him are putting
[ __ ] out there and it's like all
right who okay
if it's supposed to be a president you
know you're supposed to be some level of
like
vetting with what you say and what you
do
and suddenly now you have this prominent
figure using social media
and saying crazy [ __ ] all the time
and suddenly it's like okay everyone's
like wait a second okay so so we flag
his tweets
we're gonna fly we're gonna put a little
a little
present from twitter
is it too far gone now because it's like
we went four years of that and then but
then everybody else started doing it
yeah like everybody else in these
positions started doing it too i know
well it's weird because it's like every
like now this whole like joe rogan
spotify thing they're like okay
all right everyone's tr everyone's angry
at us so we'll we'll put a little eye
with a circle next to it
like oh by the way covered missing from
it's like okay it's
so it's like there's tiny little baby
steps here and there kind of happening
now with like
this concept of like platforms and
responsibility but it's like one of
those like
i don't know it's yeah it's like you
drop your phone and you bump it with
your foot you know it's like that kind
of like
it's that it's like that it's that level
of effort
to like fix a problem you know yeah i
mean you definitely have like like back
in you know before the internet you had
central
you know news sources basically you know
you had basically the big three channels
abc cbs nbc i probably missed one um fox
like old fox
and you know so they had their new shows
and that's where you get your
information so there were there were
gatekeepers the news and while they
certainly
purported to
you know try to uphold a certain value
of truthfulness and they did to some
extent
there's also of course just natural bias
and control of information that would
come from that and of course trying to
actually sell views and all that kind of
stuff
and like now there is no gatekeeper and
anybody can post anything which the
whole using the news to get views has
only been exactly another different
thing though that's happening since
since since the since the rise of
digital media well there hasn't been a
you haven't had a commitment to
truthfulness necessarily like you had a
commitment to truthfulness back from
that day but now there is no commitment
to truthfulness what i'm saying is part
of the reason of that is because people
now aren't paying for their media
anymore right they're paying they pay by
view we pay by ads and that's yeah you
pay by pay by ad and then therefore now
you're clicking on something rather than
getting a newspaper sent to you or
rather than watching it on broadcast
television where it's like
subsidized and paid by major advertising
i think it's how it clicks
i think it goes one level deeper than
all that which is the whole point of the
internet and these social media
platforms is to give everyone a voice
and so suddenly now seven billion people
have a voice
how do you regulate
thought
yeah because that's basically what is
happening here we're like we're at a
point in time where it's like okay
anyone can upload a video to youtube so
cool now it's versus like that
technology being within a small number
of hands so like unfortunately it comes
back to maybe it's like it's a new
concept here because you can't regulate
thought and when everyone has access to
upload whatever whatever they want
then suddenly it's like well how do you
regulate that how do you
regulate every
image of a child in a youtube video and
how do you rate whether that's a channel
designed to
profit off of ad dollars or is that just
someone's like home movies channel i
feel like there's a really simple answer
to it uh like let me just let me just
throw out a casual easy answer
[Laughter]
the most complex problems of the 21st
century it boils down to in my opinion
if you are curating the content on your
server on your platform in any way
literally if you have an algorithm and
it's not just like sorted by
chronological upload date you know but
if you actually come and like come up
with a way to say okay i'm going to put
this in front of you i'm going to hide
this you are now deciding you are now
stating things you are now saying this
is true this is not this needs to be
viewed this isn't you the moment you
start curating your media is the moment
you are no longer just a platform and
you are now a publisher
and
if people want to say whatever they want
to say they can pay for their own web
hosting and put it up on their own
website go for it right if you want to
see what they're going to say and it's
going to go on to youtube and youtube's
going to be like hey you know it's just
whatever it's an open platform free
speech it's like no you have an
algorithm it's not free speech you are
curating this stuff that's where the
laws of libel and slander all need to be
reapplied and they're not you know yeah
all that stuff does exist there are
legal worlds so [ __ ] up right now it
would be so easy to like just step
forward
i totally [ __ ] agree i totally agree
and i i think it's i think it's fine
for like youtube to be like we want to
ban these channels because we think
they're doing misinformation go for it i
don't give a [ __ ] who they are whether i
agree with them or not
but i think they should have have every
power to do that and everyone who's like
complaining about being canceled or like
yeah you know social media it's like
[ __ ] you yeah well you're on so many
other companies websites you make your
own website it cost you five dollars a
month
[Applause]
the argument the argument is that
it isn't just their website it is now
the platform for public speech
that's what instagram facebook and
youtube but they're not tick-tock but
you're saying you're having your cake
and eating it too though nico you're
saying no it is you are a publisher as
soon as you apply an algorithm but
screw the people who get you can kick
off because
that's not youtube i'm being very
consistent i'm saying
it is a corporate platform it is their
own website and they are curating stuff
and they can do whatever they want with
it and if you have a problem with it
go make your own website like
obviously you know voice your complaints
do all that kind of stuff try to make
youtube a better place that's awesome
why then why do they need to be
regulated then
because they are actively publishing
things without vetting them because they
they hide behind that the oh we're a
platform
and you know we don't curate we're so
it's an open thing when it's not they do
right but there you're so but you're
saying there's an inherent aspect of
like public speech that's happening i'm
saying like if you you know if youtube
is taking a video somebody's going out
and saying that uh you know
the election was is a bunch of fraud
right
and it's it's not truthful and then
youtube takes that and sticks it in the
little algorithm and okay now it's to go
out in front of a million new people
youtube is deciding to publish that and
they are now publishing misinformation
and that is youtube that is doing that
it's kind of the same issue that uh they
had that whole lot and youtube was
trying to get all of its different users
to like write into the eu to tell them
not to pass that law i can't remember
what it's called but basically the law
was saying like hey it's it's not the
person who uploads it to your service
that's responsible for the copyright
infringement it's you who owns the
services
yeah i think you're missing a few things
though in your analysis
what about the physical location
metaphor
a town or a company makes like a big
square where everyone can go to talk
and they put like sharp objects
everywhere and so you go there to talk
and then you hurt yourself and you're
like look no you anyone can come here
it's your own thing it's like no you're
you're responsible for that space to
keep this space like
free of danger since you're like paying
for it or hosting it it's like
you would still be like i'm suing the
platform not like suing other people
around you know it's like i don't know
yeah like if i took my computer and i
opened it up to the internet i'm like
hey keep my computer and like somebody
comes and like starts and stores a bunch
of child porn on it so other people can
come and grab it i came back oh
you know whatever it's an open platform
like no it's your computer
[Laughter]
you're still saying you're still saying
though that there is some arbiter of
truth
in this context well yeah i've been
talking about like regular
regular slander libel all those kind of
things that do apply
you know a newspaper can't go out and
just say
completely factually false things about
say another person or another company
without getting into potential legal
trouble but youtube has hidden behind
the whole like oh it's not it's not our
content it's somebody else's content
we're just hosting it it's like well no
you're actually publishing it which is a
different right
right but
you are also then saying okay so
take the
misinformation example okay now there's
misinformation it doesn't matter what it
is
right it's it's it's uh
who is this arbiter of what the what the
main
what is in between this misinformation
right if i'm like okay you you don't
want you want to you want to remove the
uh
election fraud misinformation
covered misinformation
there's a concept of truthfulness and uh
what's the term i'm looking for here
but
acting with best intentions things like
that there is a concept here that you
can tell when somebody is bullshitting
you
versus somebody talking about something
that you know maybe there's things that
you haven't quite figured out yeah i
agree i agree like you look instagram
thing is a great example there you go
it's like when you look at stuff
look
look at zuckerberg's
congress interview and it's like so
obvious that he's just hiding behind
his own platform right right pretending
like he doesn't have control over it
um
but i i
i think it's important to recognize that
these are public platforms but they're
not they're not like they're private
see i know you you you're that's that's
the distinction i'm trying to make here
is you're saying no these are private
companies in and of their entirety
so but then when the government comes in
and is like hey we need to do something
because
your
actions are affecting the greater public
then they hide behind and they go no
it's not us it's the user we're a
private company not a public company not
a government asset you know not not a
yeah
none of the first amendment doesn't
apply and you're you're vehemently
saying that now that they can do
whatever they want because they're a
private company
what about the public impact could you
say the same thing about an oil company
could you say the same thing about an
energy company yeah it's a private
company but if they don't deliver the
energy then you don't have electricity
and now all of a sudden there's a public
impact there where they're profiting off
of it and they have now a moral and
social responsibility to beyond that's
beyond just like hey i'm a private
company leave me alone
and i think
to deny the fact that that exists about
these platforms is i mean it's totally
at the end of the day it becomes a
simple question of whether or not it's a
private company
it's not a simple question
the companies are so
no it's not it's a company
they're so large and they have such an
egregious impact on the public at large
you cannot honestly sit there and say
that they have no public impact or
they're not published no that's how i'm
saying that's what i'm saying at all but
once again i think the oil thing is a
great meta or a great analogy actually
because
you know
there's
tons of regulations surrounding
how and where
you know things need to be approved
you're not going to just put up an oil
well somewhere randomly and then tell
people later it's like no
we're gonna we're we're sending
geologists to this area we're sending
like marines and
wildlife scientists to this area we're
studying it we're getting things written
down it's all approved it's regulated
how it's transferred how it's extracted
there's safety precautions surrounding
the entire process
how it can be sold is regulated as well
where it can go like the entire process
because of that public impact
it's highly regulated you know and now
granted an oil spill happens yes
the oil company then suddenly gives all
the politicians bonuses to get a lot of
leniency and subvert yeah and they put
ads about how friendly they are on on
public television
we're sorry we're scrubbing the clothes
and granted there's an entire slew of
issues but it's still at the at its base
you know we have that there is because
of the public impact there is the
regulatory structure to try and keep it
in its lane so that way it doesn't
become too chaotic and it it keeps
consistency
um so it's like
i see i mean i feel like
so so yeah by that measure it's kind of
like well these are huge companies too
they have a huge public impact
so
why aren't the regulations there to
force them
into their lane
it would be it would be useful for the
for the public at large but it also does
bring up the first the first amendment
in the free speech question
but it's not a government institution so
like this is what you're saying niko
if you had a company that was so large
that it was denying everybody due
process of law such that they were just
like some company that was just like
entirely circumventing some fundamental
right but they can do that but they can
do whatever they want with their
platform
this is their platform it's that simple
and like if there's bad problems because
of that then you've got to deal with it
yeah so
you don't get to just like like the laws
aren't going to really apply because
this is a little bit of a funky
situation like no it's it's a private
company and it's a private platform and
honestly if we were if we were strict
about our applications of what that
means it would kind of eliminate a
couple of these problems that we're
talking about you know it's it's either
embrace it as a private platform or it's
not a private platform at all which of
course it isn't it's saying it's a
private platform within a with a huge
public impact but
also does not need to adhere to public
practices that the government would
otherwise need to adhere to that's
literally what usually they do not of
course they don't they can do whatever
they want
our studio and says something really
stupid what is the purpose of the
government then what is the purpose of
the government then if not to if not to
act as a buffer between a great public
if we're going to get into a deep talk
about first amendment rights and how
much that should be adhered to outside
of public institutions this is not
really the space here's so here's the
problem here's the problem talking about
this is the perfect space for it
there's a podcast about a bunch of video
creators on youtube what are you talking
about well i'm
i mean i think i'm just gonna say this
don't hate me i call into the question
whether it's worth listening to everyone
with free speech is cool and i agree the
first amendment is very important right
i don't want i'm not saying the first
amendment is bad
but when
everyone has the power of a magnifying
glass to like say dumb [ __ ] magnifying
glass or megaphone megaphone
[Laughter]
handing go like free speech is good but
then if the government is forced to
supply megaphones to everyone
i think that i don't think that's a good
idea look at the end of the day here i
just wanna i'm not sure a lot of people
confuse this the first amendment and you
know this jake i'm not saying this to
you
the first amendment only applies to the
government but it always says the
government it means you can't go to jail
and you can't be deprived of your
liberty yeah for saying something
whether it's smart or stupid right
there's certain obviously there's a
couple very specific restrictions but
yes naturally but yeah and like and that
only applies to the government you know
if youtube wants to be like look no
talking about guns on youtube which does
it okay it doesn't they can do that it
doesn't just apply to the government it
doesn't does yes
it doesn't apply to a company
a company can be like hey we only hire
christians here no they can do that the
government can't if it's just i don't
think so here's i'll give you an example
i'll give you an again it kind of can't
a company can totally do that as long as
you don't say it
[Laughter]
first line
first of all no you you guys are you
guys are going down a little bit of a
path which is is is some of the argument
against
you're establishing
core concepts which are some of the
arguments against
this idea that no they're a private
company they can do whatever you want
you don't like it start your own
platform um and that's this thing these
like
first and foremost
if if let me give you an example
if i'm a company a private company and i
organize all say i have 500 employees
and i say all 500 employees go out into
a public square
and
incite a riot
incite violence heavily illegal yes
why would that be illegal because
inciting a right and citing violence is
like right right
we didn't say we we
all we did was say things
all we did was say things but that is an
illegal thing to do you cannot say
certain things why is that illegal it's
illegal you can deny somebody the right
of free speech
somebody's free speech can be taken from
them not by necessarily a government the
government is now is not the government
is not the one who is
is protecting the right they're taking
it away
right there's very specific places it
applies like for example
libel slander yelling fire in a crowded
theater is the classic example right you
can't put other people you can't incite
violence you can't cite danger you can't
mortally threaten somebody but you're
saying the first amendment the
protections of the first amendment
only apply to the government
no
i'm saying that the protections of the
first amendment
are limitations of the government
the government cannot pick an official
religion the government cannot house
troops in your house the government
cannot search your private property
without a warrant warranty
[Music]
you're saying this
you don't deny
that these platforms have a massive
global
impact on information
and equality no i'm not denying that
human rights i'm not denying that that's
an obvious you're not denying that at
all
yeah you're saying that they have no
obligation to
make maintain free and open discourse as
you would in a free society they have an
obligation but not a legal obligation
and i'm saying
why why isn't there a legal obligation
at this point they should
because there is a there is a
distinction between something legal
something moral something that you
simply just want to provide for the
users you know if the people of youtube
don't value
an open platform
they don't like netflix is not an open
platform people still value it and use
it you know it's like there's a whole
it's like that reflex is not a public
speech flat platform though
i mean i just
i don't understand how you're separating
public speech you're separating public
speech and free and open discourse i
mean i don't know how you can separate
those two things yeah but it's like
saying sorry hey guys meet up we're
meeting up at the the pizza shop
cheese we're meeting up at chuck e
cheese every friday night to talk about
uh sports and then chuck e cheese's
clothes and or they say
you know hey guys like you got to stop
meeting here like we have a party
tonight they pick something a little
more like not kid friendly we're gonna
meet up at chucky cheese to talk about
our freaking uh
[Laughter]
to make you're trying to make my
argument sound more clowny no i'm not
that's right chuck e cheese i get it but
what what's really a straw man in a
chuck e cheese what's really interesting
is
these these platforms put themselves out
there as public speech platforms right
became massively rich and successful as
public speech platforms and then when we
are asking the government to regulate
them as public speech platforms and to
protect free speech and open discourse
they're you're then saying oh no but
they don't have to do that
no i'm saying
i'm saying they aren't public speech
platforms i'm saying they are private
platforms exactly how can you say that
i'm not saying they're not they can't be
regulated they're not
say they're not public speech platforms
i absolutely are you're saying
we need to regulate them as publishers
but they're not public speech platforms
are they owned by the government are
they owned by the public nothing to do
with it that has nothing to do with it
you're saying they need to be regulated
you know youtube isn't youtube is an
advertising i think it's cool
and not get as animated as i am about
this but you are fundamentally incorrect
in this
if nature was a public speech platform
it wouldn't run ads
you you cannot sit there and say that
something is a public something is not a
public speech platform but needs to
adhere to the obligations of publishers
you can't do it
you can't do it whether it's youtube
reddit tick tock twitter or any other
public speech platform they are private
companies and they can do what you just
called it a public speech
they can do whatever the heck they want
with their servers with their rules with
their guidelines because they are
private companies
they need to be treated like publishers
then stop saying that so therefore
therefore the stuff on their servers the
stuff they are publishing
it is under like they are responsible
for it if they end up publishing
something that say starts a riot they
are responsible for it it's on their
servers and they are publishing it it's
not that they're doing it passively they
are actively influencing an algorithm to
decide what people want to look at what
they don't want to look at you upload
platforms and then they go like i like
this video let's put it through the
title and then they're like hey a lot of
people are watching this yeah we're
gonna we're gonna push this and
recommend this so that a ton of people
see this yeah and they need to be held
responsible for that as any private
entity would and and then they're saying
on the same
then you're saying with the other hand
that they can take away whatever types
of speech that they want from their
platform yeah they can what if i'm
making
i don't think i feel like you're making
arguments and then we're making
arguments yeah
these aren't meshing because like i feel
like you're you have a different version
of this conversation than i do right now
whatever they want they've banned stuff
all the time so like okay let's make
let's break it down real simple jordan
yeah jordan writes down break it down
some wacky stuff all right and i read it
and i go and i look at this wacky stuff
all right and then i'm gonna go
you know what i think
jake and nico really gotta see this
stuff so i give it to both of you guys
and you see it
and then a few minutes later
you guys start breaking stuff you bust
my windows and or someone's windows and
i'm then i'm like okay whose fault was
that
who's who's at fault here was that
jordan for saying hey giving me a note
that says hey breaks this guy's windows
or is it my fault for saying you know
who would like to see this in fact let's
listen to you guys it's both of your
faults so it's both of our faults it's a
shared fault so it's it's basically yeah
it's jordan's fault for ins doing the
initials
and then it's actually my fault my
windows for then going you know what
you know what according to everything i
know on how to make money and get views
in order to profit
off of this crazy message that says
break windows i know the exact people to
give it to
and then i and so now i'm profiting off
of his and right his inciting a riot you
know
mm-hmm it's just supposed to be for fun
you know the metaphor really
you know so it's a metaphor but like
that's the thing it's like now i'm
profiting off of like the a business
decision you know this is this is how
they go oh
this is how we should act as a company
is by taking this type of information
and doing x with it you know
in order to make money my point i think
sam illustrated well but jake my point
of view at the end of the day
is that by thinking of these companies
as private entities which they are and
really be adhering to that
along with that comes the responsibility
that they need to have as well as the
punishments for not following those
responsibilities you know a private
entity they are responsible for
publishing like the newspaper is
responsible for publishing
things you know
and that that carries over to something
like youtube twitter or anything else
it's going to be publishing information
they haven't
agreement on the idea that
regulation would be useful as a public
good
but i think fundamentally you are coming
at it from a slightly different angle in
the sense of like
this whole
idea about
like free speech you're saying it
doesn't matter they can push whatever
kind of information and speech that they
want to but if they push the wrong
speech
whatever that is
then they get in trouble so what you're
doing though is you're creating this
totally arbitrary arbitrary arbiter of
truth
and then you're saying i don't know
right because if you're wrong and it
incites a riot i'm not introducing an
arbiter of truth i think that's where we
need to be clarifying here
i am applying the laws that already
exist for all of this stuff there are
already regulations for how uh how all
this stuff works you cannot publish
certain things you cannot say certain
things and news articles are written for
traditional media they still apply they
still apply easily as you
they updated the copyright act in 1976
after 100 years of copyright
infringement they were like what do we
do let's update it in 1976. you think
that we can't update our laws to fight
the technologies
i'm not saying we even need to all i'm
saying is that laws already exist that
handle the problems that we're dealing
with they just simply need to be applied
maybe that's where you and i disagree
then i think i just wanted to get to the
bottom of that and youtube you and i
disagree because you're saying no
they're they should they're private
companies they need to be treated as
such and however you like that or don't
like it it's fine they can say that
there's uh election fraud they can say
that men can be pregnant no no it
doesn't matter no i want to be clear i
want to be clear you can't publish
certain things
as a private company if you go out right
but
my point my point was if they say those
things and people get hurt because of it
or they're blatantly lying and they get
into trouble yes right yes okay
but and i'm just saying that
the the application of the pre-existing
laws to the situation that we're in now
in 2022
is is not it's not enough it's not
enough i'd agree with that i think we
need to obviously update things but
obviously stuff does exist that covers a
lot of the issues we're already dealing
with yes there's a foundation obviously
it's not like we're wholly without law
in this area yeah and i also want to
throw it out there that
there is a difference at least in my
mind the stark difference between just
because something is legal doesn't mean
it's what you want to do or it's the
right thing to do
you know of course there's a difference
of that yeah so when i say like it
should be this way i don't mean like
that's functionally how it should be i
just mean that's the legal structure
you know around it should be a certain
way but how people want to act obviously
they have their own decisions beyond
that i mean it's a little abstracted
here i understand i understand the only
point i was trying to make is that
we we now need to can start to consider
these platforms as public platforms
they're public utility almost like
platforms like the internet perhaps
i don't think so at all i mean these are
massive
media and data and informational
platforms upon which people are popping
up all the time though they're popping
up all the time well yeah i'm not saying
every single social media platform
everyone's saying
ones of a certain scale
like you can literally look at the
economics of it i think just what it all
really boils down to whether it's public
or private
there needs to be a certain amount of
responsibility for what they are
actively publishing and pushing on their
platforms because which is something
they are deciding to do
privately you know when facebook decides
to tweak the algorithm to publish images
to young teenage girls that harms their
body image that's facebook's decision to
do that and it needs to be treated
accordingly public entity private entity
doesn't matter facebook's a company they
took that action and that's the
repercussion and it needs to be attached
directly to their decisions which they
actively made to do that you know and so
you're saying that right inside that and
fog that up but it's not a complicated
issue it's very simple
facebook very clearly had an engineer
make the algorithms that do that and
they know how it works it's very simple
you can change that but your argument is
is they they should they they need to
change it or get in trouble or peep the
free market will create another platform
is that your argument to solve the
problem
my no no my argument is there i think i
believe there are already laws in place
that would get them in trouble for that
action and the reason those laws have
not been applied is for a myriad of
reasons there's two categories by the
way by the way i think the confusion is
because we're talking about two
categories here okay we're talking about
category a which is the private
platforms they can ban or treat users
however they wish
okay they they create a narrative
and the content is conformed to the
private company's narrative mm-hmm all
right they're terrifying do they have a
right to do that
well
big companies have been terrifying
for right much longer than social media
no no i'm not throwing my hands up i'm
saying it's a persistent problem that
critical thinking and awareness can
overcome you see a corporate gas station
message saying hey we're making the
future a better place by selling gas and
you're like cool uh you know actually i
know there's other people doing it i'm
using critical thinking
i know this is all [ __ ] you know
cool i subverted the corporate narrative
in a millisecond piece of cake
so that's easy to deal with um so then
the other end of this is
kind of totally different this is the
sugary serial ads paired with children's
tv shows concept
and that that's a completely different
category we're talking about here as
well which is that is a different
category yeah yes but so we've been kind
of
intertwining these arguments which is
why i think it's getting a little yeah
confusing here you know like obviously
you know google can't get in trouble
for having a guy who goes like dude put
this thing up your butt and here's your
code you know it's like
google's not gonna like get into trouble
by the government but the same thing you
know themselves that to
you know everything made that the number
one video on the site for like five days
you're like well google you're kind of
backing that message now well i mean
yeah you're right and obviously now but
so well i guess now we start
intertwining these categories once again
let's say some five people die because
they put the wrong thing up their butt
it didn't cure their coveted and they
died so whose fault does that happen
with the with this legit happen with the
tide pods no now here's the thing whose
fault is it google right was it youtube
or was it the stupid person in the video
here's the point that i'm trying to make
i keep going back to this free speech
thing and da da da da what i'm saying is
that the best ideas in a world where you
cannot control thought right the best
ideas god damn it that actually get to
the top that people actually follow
are only
only come about
through free disc through open discourse
and it needs to be and there's a line
don't get me wrong i'm not saying i
don't just allow narratives that are
stupid or people take advantage of or
are completely blatantly misinformation
but i'm saying there is a ton of gray
area there's a ton of grey areas and
people are going to say things you don't
like and you can't just berate the
platform when it's when it's a
effectively public speech platform to
just say this needs to be off of here
which is exactly what they're doing with
joe rogan right now exactly what they're
doing people who haven't even seen his
episodes who don't even know anything
about him they've just heard sound bites
and yadda yadda they're saying spotify
you need to do this da da da da
was treated as a public platform that it
was required to uphold free speech
that wouldn't even be an issue it
wouldn't even be a thing that was
decided by the corporation i don't think
i don't think we should be holding like
platforms like that to a free speech
legal
test that said i think you and i are
both in agreement
that free speech regardless of whether
you're a private or public entity is
still an ideal that should be pursued
because open discussion is important but
it does bring up to mind you know
right now with the way things work work
whether it's advertising based or view
based people aren't necessarily wanting
the truth and this is a bit of an issue
i've had with reddit recently where
you're not getting the truth when things
are uploaded you're getting what people
want to believe is true and one of the
most common like mysteries i read about
all the time is is so for example people
talk about hey should there be an oscar
for stunts right
and then immediately somebody triumphs
in well
well you know the problem is if they had
an oscar for stillness people would just
try to one-up each other with the most
dangerous stunts so that's why they
don't have it it's like that person has
no idea how stunts work they have no
idea how the industry works that is not
what qualifies a good stunt is how
dangerous it is that's not how it works
well if they legalize marijuana then
everyone's just gonna want to do heroin
man don't you know
so i you know i say that and i say it
nicely at first
when i say that and it gets down voted
because people don't want that to be the
truth they want the truth to be that
stunts aren't allowed or awards aren't
allowed for stunts because people want
to try to one-up each other for danger
and so the truth doesn't matter what
people want to believe matters on sites
like reddit where you have yeah like
also like people vote that one picture
of the cortana from the halo series
that's coming out and they're like
something's wrong with this this is
janky and it's like no that's not the
truth there's nothing wrong with cortana
it's the whole series
the whole halo series is janky and
you're pretending like they got one
thing wrong it's like no
everything's wrong
it's like
on the discord now like we should fix
cortana's janky face like
where do we be like
that's like
halfway through the trailer we're gonna
take shots from the trailer we're gonna
start at the beginning like
this is stupid
i've been wanting to we're going to talk
about this more than vfx artist draft
probably
because there's some great visual
effects but the whole thing's stupid
yeah it's not just now
there's entitled there's a lot of [ __ ]
out there i i don't like that
this has been bubbled up and i just
found the closest segue to you
sorry
i really don't like shitism culture i
think it's really toxic but i all i'm
saying is uh
there's a
um
[Music]
i'm gonna sum it up here's the thing
there's a difference between something
being harmful
and like
and becoming true misinformation and
there's a difference between that and
something
that hurts your feelings or makes you
feel bad and i'm not saying bad things
where people say something that hurts
your feelings people need to [ __ ] nut
up
all right there's gonna be plenty of
that [ __ ] out there but that being said
right now the this is the problem with
the platforms is that they're saying oh
yeah we're like banning harmful users
like no right now you're banning a lot
of non-harmful users that are saying
things that are getting other people
angry because they disagree and
unfortunately this focus seems to be on
this like [ __ ] emotional argument
concept
instead of the actual harmful things
that are happening
on these platforms all right whether
it's tide pod [ __ ]
or it's child abuse you know like there
are actual problems in front of us that
people see on social media and
unfortunately because of the platform
thing they take the pc approach and say
all right you know these two people are
having a disagreeing political argument
well
which one should we ban who
which user should we keep on the
platform versus which one should and
like it's it seems to be centered around
this like petty emotional discussion
whereas i think there's larger problems
that we're all starting to see
especially when taking into account you
know the the publisher role that they
are growing and
they're they're they're assuming this
role more and more
as the platforms grow yeah i think
that's a good summary i just want to say
that anybody who's made it this far in
the podcast including jordan
is gonna go on by himself now monologue
for the next 20 minutes
right
post
[Laughter]
love to hear people's thoughts in the
comments below all right who should he
ban we're not trying to tell anybody
what to think about
all we're doing is we're sharing what we
think
you're right that is that is what's
going on you comment at the comments
comment below we should ban from the
quarter cast in order to make a more
peaceful quarterback
jordan's too nice and agreeable i know i
know but other things are happening too
that's what things are
they're like
who should we ban
i don't know i just who what do you
think greg uh i i don't know um
that's that's it you nailed it
at the end of the day
it's all just for shits and giggles
right it's all social media it's all for
them likes all right yeah like and
subscribe guys have a good night wow
[Laughter]
beautiful guys later
catch you later
i'm losing my mind all right guys i'm
gonna i'm going to just swiftly begin
walking i respect it away
and uh that was a great great chat very
fiery can't wait to talk about halo more
we're gonna break this halo crap get a
little eventually
almost feel good no actually no
tomorrow's bollywood so
we're doing bollywood which is even
better
i cannot reveal i cannot wait to reveal
these bollywood secrets that i've
learned
they are so good
all right so everybody thanks for
listening later